all right ladies and gentlemen we are
live what's going on b hey what's going
on man
all right all right all right we are
live uh
they're in kenosha wisconsin
right now couldn't be a better place to
be
yeah i know it's cold up there oh my i
can't even
imagine down here in cincinnati today
was freezing
i can't imagine how cold it is well i
can look it up
that's gotta be cold but the other day
it was snowing during the rally
yeah yeah yeah and hopefully
hopefully they have um some
transportation
for um yeah oh
i'm wearing those debacles all right so
we are live right now um let's see
oh my goodness um for all of you that
are watching on facebook youtube
periscope uh parlor cloudhub
thank you so much for tuning in
this is the kenosha one correct
i just actually jumped into the one that
you were in
i hope i don't know i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure it is right yeah yeah
yeah because he's in grand rapids at um
at 10 30. so uh she's in the wrong one
that's not good i hate the sound on that
one
kenosha yeah commercial
wait a minute all right
okay no no actually no
no no we're right the kenosha one what's
up everybody
um it looks like it looks like she
is in the michigan one right now yeah
i'm gonna drop her the link
before she said i logged into both
i don't know how you could do that but
whatever yeah
uh let's see let's see we're waiting for
president trump
to show up with uh all the beautiful
people we got friends in the building
um damien from france says that we want
trump
um
oh make sure you share the show guys i
please
not that i forgot but i didn't i just
remembered
yeah make sure you share so thank you um
thank you are a eight big fan wayne keep
up the great work
um let's see mary says what's your
prediction there brian
oh my prediction um donald trump's got
this
uh hands down if you look at rallies you
look at the enthusiasm
compared that with 2016 and 2012 go all
the way back
barack obama when he won his enthusiasm
and his crowds were larger than that
that he ran against
and now we're seeing donald trump's
rallies dwarfed
hillary clinton's and now they're
dwarfing joe biden
newt gingrich said today and i agree
with him that the black vote and the
hispanic vote are waning
for joe biden they're they're not liking
the choice
and you're going to see a lot of people
sit out for this election for the
democrat party
you think so i do i do i really do the
enthusiasm for trump is just
it's enormous it's through the roof the
win is going to be
so big it's going to shock everybody and
i i'm
i'm predicting that the left is going to
be so shocked
that it's going to be cheat city all day
that's that's what they're going to run
with the media's going to run with it
democrats gonna run with it
trump had to have cheated there's no way
he could have
well so much well yeah i mean i already
see i already see um like um dan
abrams is uh has already said that um
that um that the trump is gonna try to
cheat already and i don't even know
where that comes from but then it comes
from a
projection type of thing because
republicans are saying that the
democrats are trying to
trying to cheat too right
i think i think um i think somebody said
did you
see the kamala video yesterday i don't
even want to go into that one
all right
let me just say yeah go ahead that that
i made a couple phone calls
and wayne uh you're
you're probably more right than you know
you are
but to think the thing what are the odds
think about that
think about the odds that
that our good friend would happen to
be in the same street address
at the same time there you go a
fake wannabe camilla
yeah prancing around yeah what what
better way to take a viral video
i was like i was like i mean when i saw
it
and i looked at the long limousine i was
like when did they start going to long
limousines
nope everything that we have been seeing
was straight up black suv right and
i drove for ivanka i drove for mike
pence
i've been involved in all of these
whenever they come to town
they are always the big giant
yukons the big giant blacked out suvs
nobody does limos nobody and that was a
long one
and something else that i told you was
it's a couple days before the the
general election
usually the the president and the vice
president have their security detail
because they are everybody's getting
daily briefings now about what's going
on in
around the world and stuff even though
you're uh
um what uh uh just a candidate
a candidate you're still getting
briefings about what's going on
because just as soon as you win if you
win then you take over and you just
start flowing within what
is going on well not only that but you
are surrounded with
security detail right but joe biden is
former vice president
so he's always had right right detail
right
now he pulled camella on board he's
certainly going to give her detail
right so to say that camilla showed up
in miami
somewhere with with a big chunky
white-haired dude that could have been
his first name could be bill
i don't know it's possible
i wish i knew what you guys were talking
about
there was a video yesterday was it
yesterday it was yesterday i don't
what whenever it was yeah over the
weekend
where laura loomer
oh yeah yeah i know what you're talking
about they're saying it was that woman
from snl
trying to get into character so they
just use her to see how
easily it would work and if it didn't
work then she was going to come out and
say surprise it's me from saturday night
live
but it actually worked so she didn't
it didn't oh yeah they got they got
found out yeah and they turned
tail and they got up out there they
yeah they were embarrassed i knew it was
i think it was something crazy because i
was like
she well even though kamala did get some
surgery and stuff
i was like that's a white woman why
would they do that
what's the point of doing that well
here's it spread like wildfire on
um social media with conservatives oh
she got a body double
right right
what better way to get attention
uh if you're a republican
and you've been on person wasn't she
yelling at her
yes she she was young on the spot she
was on the spot
uh laura lima was yelling at the uh
camilla harris look-alike yeah yeah
yeah ladies and gentlemen once again we
are waiting for the uh
the plane to touch down it was kind of
neat last night
uh lee and i was doing the show and we
saw the
the lights or the plane light come from
the sky
and like land it was it was kind of cool
man
i mean it was really cool all of you
right now that are watching
thank you so much trump will okay there
kathy kathy says trump is going lose by
a huge
landslide okay well kathy why would you
say that
what is it just a gut feeling is it just
your personal opinion
well i mean give me something give me
something what makes you say that
karen says the dems message is negative
all they have is attacking trump and his
supporters
djt is a positive mention of a strong
america which is what we need
you know we um i guess
what's his name kathy yes
i guess kathy uh wants to
elect this guy i'll lead an effective
strategy to mobilize
true international pressure that is the
song i would have to play to get you
hyped up aretha franklin's
respect
your son's uh there is no controversy
but my
five grandchildren who range in age from
27 to uh to 14 or no that's not true 16.
can send every single qualified person
to a four-year college in their state
for 150 billion
after our interview mr biden's staff
told us he misspoke
and that the cost of free public college
could be twice as much
four more years of george georgia he
uh we have put together i think the most
extensive and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of american
politics
i'm sorry kathy he said voter fraud
cassie just has a hate for trump you
have to understand they're not voting
they're not voting for biden they're
voting to get trump out
no one is voting provided no no one is
voting for biden they're voting to get
trump out
they don't care if it's a dead dog
laying inside the highway if that's
who's running for
the democrat party they're going to vote
for the dead dog
they're not voting for joe they're
voting to get trump out
you know that's funny you say that sean
hannity had a man on the street
ordeal today and the guy was in new york
and he was asking voters in new york
if if there was voter fraud
and trump won would that be okay and
they said absolutely not
lock it down if there was voter fraud
and biden one
would that be okay and they all of them
virtually said
yes that would be fine because that's
the right thing to do
however he wins by hook or by crook and
then he started asking him
if biden wins but you got to punch your
mom in the face
would that be okay i'm not lying he
really said this to these people
said yes i would punch my mom in the
face and she would understand
oh yes trump derangement syndrome is a
real thing they said if if joe can only
win by you punching your mother in the
face would you do it and they all said
yeah absolutely
that's fine whatever it takes and mom
would be okay mom would understand
how many people how many people out
there have uh
are waiting for tomorrow to vote how
many people out there right now
are waiting audience to vote
let's see here who's waiting to vote for
tomorrow in the audience
in the house timothy
okay so we got michelle voted two weeks
ago
wow
i know most of my friends and family
most of my friends and family are all
voting tomorrow yeah i don't know a
single person that early voted
i don't have a single person on my
facebook account that is republican that
early voted
i have five democrats that have no
republicans
north carolina republicans outpace
democrats
for nine days and are outpacing
democrats now
with the likes that's never been seen
like that in north carolina
what are your um give the give the
people a link
so that they can see that let people
know where you found that
at i don't think his cousin has a
oh link pregnant no that's not my cousin
well you weren't giving a leg you hadn't
dated so you gave me a good job
you know i got my other phone i'm trying
to find a link
to pull a link out of my you know what
come on both of you well at least how's
this
guys
just joking around with you bud it's a
well i'm just saying
that it's out there that north carolina
is going huge
republicans are outpacing democrats in
early voting right and i'm still
supporting that
right and i'm saying just give the
people a link so that they can go and
research that
because notice notice we really don't
say stuff like that unless we're going
to go ahead and give people that
and stuff because we don't even report
on polls like that
because we don't believe in the polls no
and
again newt gingrich did say that i saw
that on fox news
honest opinion right and and we know
what they did with the polls last year
we know they got it wrong last year
because they out polled
dems more than republicans because the
pollsters believed
that more americans were democrat um
and so his personal opinion is if you
see a poll add seven to trump and you're
probably close
i agree well the thing is
without even looking at any polls you
have to look at it this way
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna listen to
anybody and i'm not going to listen to
the media i'm going to see
what i see with my own eyes i'm seeing
huge trump rallies i'm seeing huge trump
get-togethers all across the united
states
huge trump trains uh huge
trump parades that's what i'm seeing
with my eyes
i'm not seeing huge joe rallies i'm not
seeing joe parades and they're allowed
to in their cars even if they want to
practice social distancing
i'm not seeing huge joe trains i'm not
seeing this big enthusiasm for joe
so logically i have to go by what i'm
seeing
not what i'm hearing from the media so
what do i see
i'm seeing huge trump supporters i'm
seeing huge trump rallies i'm seeing you
know 65 000 people in butler coming out
for him with joe i'm seeing a lackluster
campaign
that's riding on the coattails of coven
so if i have to go off of what i'm
seeing not what i'm hearing
i'm going to say a trump win because of
what i'm seeing
right now and i was saying earlier
before you came on
that if you look back at the enthusiasm
and the rallies every one of of obama's
08 in 2016 he outpaced the republicans
uh there was just more people out there
down for obama hold on hold on
let's go back because
that's when i became well that's when i
left the democrat party
and i noticed there was um
it it seemed equal to me and i tell you
why
because of sarah palin it seemed
even though the media was going after
sharp anything like that it seemed like
to me that
um uh uh what's his name uh
mccain mccain what was holding big
rallies in
in huge places so to me it looked like
it was kind of level there but as we
know the democrats
like history they've always liked
history and that's what they push
they won't be the first to uh put a
black man in office they want to put
literally they want to be the first to
put a black woman up and actually they
did that with obama but
um they want to be the first to put a
black woman in office with kamala
uh they also want to be the first but i
mean
and that's just how they do but to but
to go back to what you said
i remember me there were large crowds
for sarah and um
and uh there was a lot of us back then
we really didn't
it was tough swallowing that pill for
mccain because we knew he was an
establishment rhino type
right uh but and they did it on purpose
they they got paid
because they knew they could and then
somebody put up a doctored photo of her
in a bikini holding an ar-15
yeah i remember that come on
i was younger when all that went on but
i still don't remember crowds like this
i don't ever remember them saying like
we love you
and you know i don't know i just it's
different
now this is an anomaly this is an
anomaly where yeah
we'll never will never ever see a
politician
garner this kind of support to where if
i put the flags on common dude
obama if i put the american flag on my
truck
just an american fight not a trump flag
just american flag on my truck
i know that you're a trump reporter
people will beat their horn
at me and wave and thumbs up i mean
there's a unity going on out there
that donald trump was able to unify
american people who
love america like you said i think
i think you said earlier today in the
show wayne that
that trump said biden is like i'm the
most
loyal democrat to the democrat party and
trump's like
i'm american yeah that's what it's all
about
yeah i think that's why the pollsters
get it wrong because donald trump is a
phenomenon you can't understand it you
can't grasp it and you don't really
understand why
we do but a lot of people don't and when
you don't understand it then you can't
understand why he'll win tomorrow
well most people well most people on the
other side don't deal with logic and
common sense so
true so they wouldn't understand why but
um the pre the precur i mean the
precursor to
um trump was obama and people were not
only saying i love you
they cried they snot
i mean even jesse jackson snotted on um
on tv the only the only difference that
i see
is that president trump said i love you
back and politicians don't say that
i haven't seen a politician say i love
you back uh
but i've seen many of people i mean all
the people i mean
the obama bots a lot of us were making
fun of the obama bots for
the the crazy love that they were giving
the guy and
they didn't even give him any type he
didn't have any type of experience
anything for that situation so
you know i mean look i've seen it before
i'm
i'm not going to dismiss it i've seen it
before i and and
i've seen it on this this stage
i just haven't seen uh like
where uh my co-hosts were talking about
it's the love of america and uh
when when obama was there it was a love
for obama
and america turning the corner for a
black president
with trump trump just came out the gate
straight
and everybody knew that he loved america
and everybody knew he wanted to fix
america obama didn't come out like that
so no and remember obama had the media
on his side
so whenever you look at obama's
presidency
and the enthusiasm behind it a lot of
that was created by the media
for you to get a false image of him when
really that's not what was going to be
going on and behind the scenes now we
know
how squirrely and shady obama really was
and the media helped cover that up and
the media unfortunately if they didn't
have to run these uh
rallies they wouldn't um but the proof
the proof is right there and i think
that that's where the media loses
and when we see 92 93
95 negative coverage
for one candidate versus another
you gotta look into that democrats that
are on the show right now
i i i don't i don't ever want you to
feel like i ever put you down
because i don't want to put you down i
don't name call i don't make fun of you
i just want you to question because i
question i question trump i question the
movement question what's going on
make sure i keep myself grounded please
just question why do they
hate trump so much
put your emotional feelings aside you
could hate him too that doesn't matter
put that aside
but why does the media at 90 plus
percent
oh it's the cover for the deep state
it's the cover for the democrat party
how about you leah why do you think the
media hates trump so us
well i think there's a lot of reasons
why i think the first one is
that when he was first running
they they they loved
hillary so they loved obama so much
that they didn't want to let go of that
when they know they had to because his
eight years was served
and obama influenced you have to
remember obama
influenced the media so much that they
were also under his spell
and still are so when you have somebody
like donald trump coming into it
and the media wants hillary to win they
instantly ganged up on donald trump
for hillary so donald instead of being
george w bush george w bush he never
fought back media would make fun of him
he'd just let him do it okay well they
thought that that was what was going to
happen with trump
trump didn't stand for that he fought
back he picked on them
embarrassed him to the point that he
gave them nicknames right now as we
speak they chant
cnn sucks anytime they get to this is
very embarrassing when you have a 40 50
year old news outlet
that's being discredited by the
president of the united states that they
never thought was going to get in
now they hate them so much they hate him
so much because this is their revenge
this is the only way they feel they can
get back at him
for attacking them and he was on the
defense
he was fine with the media until they
attacked him because they wanted hillary
in
so this has all been like this from the
beginning beginning they wanted obama
they wanted hillary
the only way they could get that is
making trump look bad their plan didn't
work
it backfired trump made fun of them and
now they're being discredited and
they're losing viewers by the millions
that's why they hate trump i think um
and both both of our co-hosts have
um great reasonings uh why they think
that uh the media hates donald trump my
i think mine
myself is that
in 2016 the media who had been moving
along
pushing their narratives and pushing uh
pushing the way pushing what they
thought america should be doing and
thinking and whatnot american people
looked the other way the american people
looked the other way and decided we're
not going to follow what you say
and that was a huge hiccup for the media
because the media was like wait a minute
they're going toward the other guy and
we we're trying to push them this way
right and they're going toward the other
guy and then
for the last three and a half years
the ratings have been sucking people
have been
fired they're losing money people are
going to streaming apps so they can get
away from
these news apps and whatnot
and they're losing their grip on the
american people because
there are more outlets like this show
and others that they can go to
and find out what they need to without a
whole lot of malarkey
and um and poppycock yeah well so then i
guess the question would be
not why did they hate donald so bad but
why did they push the american people so
much away from don
well no i well i still go with why they
hated him so bad because
he gave them uh they gave them an
alternative right but what i'm saying is
it's all the same answer it's all
because obama hillary
it's all no matter what it all goes back
to they didn't he didn't fit their
narrative
trump did not fit their narrative okay
i'm agreeing with you
right well uh yeah okay i i just
i don't i just saw it as a more
self-serving thing for the media rather
i mean because
it could have been joe it could have
been bernie it could have been you know
it's just that
we didn't listen to who the media wanted
period
we just decided that you know what
enough is enough
you told us who to vote for um um
selling
models in swimsuits and saltines you
know
you're trying to get us um uh to with
your attention
and we're tired of it and we're going
our own way
we turned you off we turned you off and
we turned on trump
and his twitter we turned on trump and
his facebook we turned on trump and his
youtube
we turned on trump and in the and now
yep and now the big now the big uh media
companies are trying to do the same
thing media is doing
yeah the the uh we online services
dave we had eight years of
bill clinton we had eight years
of w and then we had
eight years of barack and saint obama
the media pushed i feel like
they pushed john mccain on us
and i feel like they felt like they did
a good job
at pushing john mccain on us like he was
the warrior he was the one we needed
it was him and then the mitt romney
how how in the hell do you think
that that john q american
wants a guy that wears
mom jeans that it's a mormon and wears a
special space suit underneath his
clothes
how that's not what we wanted but that's
what the party gave us
and that was that that was no good we
were fed up
and and back then the tea party guys
were like i'm sitting this out because
i'm gonna show the republican party what
for
and i was screaming at the top of my
voice no no
no no no no you can't sell them show
them what for
looking back hindsight 50 50.
uh that's how we got trump
by sitting out by showing the republican
party yeah
we want it for you in 2010 and he gave
us no credit for us
you took all the credit you ridiculed
the tea party you really killed us who
love america
and in 2010 we gave you the house back
or to send it back and and then we gave
you the house and then we gave you trump
and you're still saying
that it's all you and it's not the
people
and i think that's that's why we got
trump
is because we knew deep down inside
the gop was against us the dnc was
against us
and so was the media um
i would play what's going on right now
it looks fun
it looks fun they dinged me earlier
from last night and all i did was i mean
i didn't play even um
oh and i even hung over top of it to try
to drown it out remember
yep yep wait i didn't like that and you
still got me
you still got me so um what time was he
supposed to start 8 30
because i haven't even seen his plane
land yet you haven't seen it either
um everything that i've seen said that
it was supposed to start at 8 o'clock so
maybe maybe the uh plane is i'm because
i know he's in
uh grand rapids the 10th well it starts
at 10 30 so
he'll probably start more like 11 like
florida's last night
because he was he was running late for
that one too uh real quick
tomorrow night we will be live and thank
you
somebody said um uh i'm not gonna
believe who wins until wayne says it
on the show thank you so much i really
appreciate that
thank you so much for that uh tomorrow
leah myself brian are going to be here
for election night coverage
starting at 6 30 p.m eastern standard
time
we will not be doing a noon show because
most of us are going to be sleeping
getting ready for the evening show but
uh well sleeping or working
and during the evening show as extra but
um
we will be here so socialism versus
america
uh we're going to be covering it from in
the end we're going to have video we're
going to talk to you on the phones
we're going to um probably hopefully
have some contests
along with that too we're working on it
right now but
we just want to let you know that we
will be here tomorrow night
covering the election so if you need
somewhere to watch it and hey
you can watch this on your tv you decide
to do is pull up youtube and type in
wayne dupree show
and you can watch us right square on
your tv
hold on
he said is there a code or a whiteboard
you want to make sure that there's some
type of code
or whiteboard so that way you can see
what's this all three of our um our
right up on your screen it'll be s3
right
like this right there
so i did my uh my light
i tampered it down a little bit so i'm
not so bright
oh yeah you see that yeah i'm not so
bright
yeah you don't look like you asked for
the ghost anymore
okay goose
and one day it was really really
different lighting for sure
let me um if i use it you know what's
strange between the
iphone 7 and the iphone 8 the camera
so much better than the iphone 8 the
iphone 8 camera
you got to try that much better you got
to try the iphone 11 camera
why i ain't there yeah i i need i need
some i need some people
me somebody tell me about it somebody
told me i'll tell you what we get
another corona to check maybe
that's a shame brian that's a shame i'm
joking come on
thanks ange and steve no i didn't show
my dog yet
tracy said did i miss leah's dog
and ange that's a nice thing to say say
to me i appreciate that
now i might show my dog it depends if uh
wayne's on board with it sometimes i
don't think he likes my dog too much any
time i say can i bring a video of my dog
on he kind of just gives me this
yeah yeah but black people and dogs
don't relate
but i have a i have a six second video i
have a six
second video of my dog watching trump
last night in florida and it's just so
cute but we'll show it at some point
yes man if we can
see he shows his fried chicken wings so
i'm sure he can give my little dog
a pass show those wings show him again
why why wouldn't you some people didn't
watch last night
okay well are you trying to make a stand
saying no that's right let's start
off
let me tell you something it's three one
it's no it's not
no it's not no it's not check the score
on our text messages
well it's wrong it's wrong you didn't
okay you doubled up somewhere and
subtracted something it's 3-1 nope
nope yeah okay okay
yeah we'll check that later we'll roll
the tape later on
whenever we want to explain my goodness
i'm not even i said i got somewhere i
got to be it would be 4-1 but wayne can
i ask you one question
so you didn't get my prank call two days
ago
with the pizza guy calling you saying he
was delivering pizzas to your house
yeah okay it should be 4-1 but for some
reason the call didn't go through
it says that maryland numbers can't be
called
after i did it and made sure that they
would record you it didn't go through i
guess
and i was wondering why you haven't
mentioned it so it's still three one
it's three months
okay all right oh thank you wayne
where's his barbecue
leah leah's playing prison rules we're
we're going prison rules are we
not going all out
the only one for prison is biden
there they are very yummy wow
that looks so good that's cosmo that's
cosmo
that one right there
that's cosmo seasoning right there it's
it's called cosmo cow
yeah cosmo cow covered yeah yep cosmo
calculator looks good
it was good too looks delish it is
delicious
yeah it looks really good all right let
me um
let me play this about
president trump while we're still
waiting for the president of the united
states
to show up the trump team put out
a video about the trump rallies and
honestly it's really good
that's beautiful i love it oh
exactly right hit brian
i don't know i'm all locked up over here
are you able to get embryon
i mean i'm on i'm on facebook's trying
to watch
and i'm like trying to comment yeah yeah
but i'll go back to my phone and go back
there to um
shout out to the watch party in facebook
pro police
pro military pro trump is a watch party
going on right now on facebook
jojo is in there she said love my trump
and love my trump supporters
god bless you all to another four great
years
so awesome there uh
i got a message from someone listening
comments said that john mccain rallies
looked bigger
because they were in such small tiny
venues
i remember when he came to cincinnati
his venues were only
maybe a thousand or so but it was a
small venue
i seen him in
i seen him in i can't mean a lot
i see him in a couple of arenas i did i
remember
i remember that because even ted cruz
toward the end
ted cruz is in the same type of arenas
that trump is in right now he wasn't at
the beginning though
but when um i know when they brought out
sarah palin
they had a lot of people there's a lot
of people in there but a good friend of
mine
is on the uh show right now watching
ronnie rhodes he says m-a-g-a
exclamation point awesome guy
i've known at the radio station for
years so glad to see some of my
old friends jumping on and watching
appreciate that
i think he's already decorated for
christmas like you brian
brian you know and so has ronnie i think
ronnie has two ronnie goes all out
though i mean
tonight i drove up to the store to get
the um
the adapter for the iphone so that i can
do the headphones and charge it at the
same time got ripped off but you know i
got it
and then there were two houses that had
lights outside
and reindeer and all kinds of stuff wow
yeah i think i'm going to go ahead and
do that too because my daughter today
was like
i said so you want to make thanksgiving
cookies and all they are just like
cookies with
a turkey like printed on them so they're
thanksgiving cookies she was like yeah
after that we can put up the tree and i
was like you know what
it's 20 20. let's do it so he's like
open up the tree
once we did that last night i'm just
you know the music we put on the 10
hours of jazz
christmas music
i bet you did my wife loved it she's
like oh this is so nice
yeah i said that what's your favorite
christmas song brian
uh i like dropping on the christmas tree
you guys ain't gonna like this but um uh
i i don't like christmas songs i get
stuck in my head
i don't like really i like i like
what you sent the music of christmas
yeah with no words but the nice
beautiful music i like that the best
yeah i like i like that too i think i
think my all-time favorite
the one that i could listen to over and
over again and over again well actually
no
there's so many though um but this one
sticks in my
mind because it was like a generation of
past
a torch pass bing crosby and
david bowie oh yeah yeah yeah
and um there's they sang a little drama
boy
but they sang it in their different
parts and oh yeah i remember that that
was so beautiful both of them and if
anybody ever gets a chance to watch
um when it showed on tv that was a cut
down version there was a longer
version on youtube um about that
so yeah a lot of people in the in the
chat saying that some like carol the
bell
silent night by the temptations uh
somebody else said
uh you remember that oh i want a
hippopotamus for christmas i remember
that that was cute
somebody in the chat said that was that
that was uh grandma got run over by
reindeer
and and there was one
uh you remember the the year that they
did we are the world
yeah okay yeah yeah okay well the
europeans
came together to do one around christmas
time too
um do they know it's christmas time
right and
to hear those european um ban
leaders on the same song and just you
know
that was kind of neat too you know they
were like hello this is sting
you know and um my name is boy george
you know
you know what hold on let me give a
shout out to those that are watching on
facebook
facebook is freaking suppressing us to
the hill
periscope still doing a great job um the
numbers are down on facebook
right now and let me tell you something
facebook
uh listen wayne before you say anything
remember people we were up to like
200 300 000 views per show
and then we got tagged for something
that wasn't even wrong
and they took us down to like 10 000
people we went from a half a million
or you know half of 500 000 yeah quarter
million
and down to this yeah that's not right
i can't even share as a as a watch party
on my own facebook page that's not a
shame i'm looking at it right now i
can't get that ashamed
as a watch party i can only share um
via it says via twitter and whatsapp
right so the folks on periscope right
now i know you don't like facebook
because you're on periscope with me
because i don't like facebook either but
for those of you on facebook please
share because that's the only way to get
it out and honestly you might have
somebody on the fence tonight
you might literally have someone on the
fence tonight who has nothing to do
and you're going to share this show and
you're going to have them watch this
speech and then they might say yeah i'm
going to vote trump and you might have
just saved a vote so think of it that
way
and if you're on facebook once you hit
the hit the button to share
scroll down a little bit and they'll be
your trump groups that you're in
and just click all of them stop at about
30 don't do more than 30 then then you
might get in trouble for that but stop
at about 30.
well shout out to the pro police pro
military pro trump
uh watch party that's going on also
voters for trump watching
awesome um pennsylvania there's a
pennsylvania for trump watching
ohio valley for trump your vote yeah
pennsylvania
you're watching i know you are i'm
seeing you you get your friends and you
vote
get as many people as you can for all
those that are on periscope
last night y'all did us a solid
you gave us some super hearts and
periscope
uh paid us they gave us a hundred
dollars they gave us a 100
contribution from from our super hearts
last night
and and i split it i split it i sure did
um because i told you i don't kee
i don't keep this stuff i i want my
co-host
to be able to pay some bills and uh
to be able to do this we're going to do
a rally right after this one
so um uh for for whatever you can give
us
give it give it to us
yeah it's a super heart and we
appreciate it
so thank you for those that gave
superhearts last night
uh the money the money was um shared
this morning
and um i don't know
yeah yeah so we're working hard for you
and remember we're gonna be back here
again at what time
uh 10 30 you said yeah 10 30. after this
we're gonna be back to 10 30
and then we're gonna try to take a break
in between now and tomorrow
yeah then we'll be we'll be back for
those that just uh jumped on we're gonna
be back tomorrow night for a marathon
show starting at 6 30 we're gonna have
all your election coverage
uh i know you can get really nervous
especially listening to fox and cnn
because they are so negative and just
so narrow-minded tunnel vision right now
we'll give it to you straight we're
gonna listen to everything we're going
to do our research
and we're going to be here for you to
tell you what's going on try to calm
your nerves a little bit
support yourself a drink and come back
here again tomorrow night at 6 30 for
our marathon show
who knows how long it's going to last
for those of you asking
how to do a super heart if you're on
your phone
if you look to the bottom right hand
corner the three
dots hit the three dots and it'll
pop open a screen and it says give super
hearts and just follow that direction
right there
and you i think you actually have to buy
something to give them but once you
click that
if you need to buy something i'll show
you how to do that right
exactly uh as we were waiting for
president trump still uh
i have another video
that we can um i i bet you those people
are cold man
but you they are cold many choosing to
brave the freezing temperatures
and they camped out earlier than early
for president trump's rally
temperature is still freezing cold out
here last time i checked it was
nine degrees my 401k is going up
everything is going up thank you donald
i love you
colorado was founded by pirates and
prospectors
cowboys and miners who came the
wilderness explored the west
and helped make this the greatest nation
ever to exist on the face of the earth
seventy-five years ago this week our
brave united states marines landed on
the shores of
iwo jima
america is truly a land of heroes
brave people great people this is a
truly incredible time for america
we have the best economy in our history
we added another 225 000
brand new beautiful jobs last month we
are in the midst of the great american
comeback that's what we're doing
our country is stronger today
than ever before
while the extreme left has been wasting
america's time
we've been killing terrorists creating
jobs raising wages
enacting fair trade securing our border
and lifting up citizens of every race
color religion and freedom
at stake in our present battle
is the survival of our nation now you
have a president who is standing up for
america and we are standing up
for the great people of colorado
america is thriving like never before
and ladies
and gentlemen the best is yet to come
i'm donald trump and i approve this
message
what happened ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen one of the greatest
things about
producing the show is that you get to
see
your co-host reactions to something that
they haven't seen before
and brian and leah were just sitting up
there marveling at that video at the
same time like
like they had just seen like the
sunshine raised up
it was a phenomenon it was
but watching both of you y'all are like
i was like when we come back they're
going to have tears
i'll tell you what i have tears for lila
gave our first super heart thank you
lila thank you
we i love lila one of the best one of
our best yeah we just had two people on
uh
on the periscope to give their first
super hearts
you guys make these rallies so worth
watching you through your
well thank you thank you we try to have
some fun with it too i mean it's just
boring if you just sit here and
talk at you you gotta have some fun yeah
yeah
yeah we gotta have fun uh gina says uh
makes me teary eyed
that was it does make you chariot
i agree last night we talked about what
your favorite part of the rally was
and i said when they chant we love you
we love you that gets me teary-eyed
uh and then wayne talked about the fact
that he wayne
loves to see all the people out and the
energy that that makes him proud
brian we didn't get to hear yours an
audience tell us what your f
what your favorite part of the rally is
but brian what's your favorite
um i just love to see americans
come together to celebrate
the greatness of america to enjoy each
other
because i've been to i've been to dozens
of these rallies guys and
most all of them i'm volunteering and
i'm helping out in them
but i get to walk around i get to talk
to everybody
i usually scope when i'm at adam and i
just
getting involved and talking to
everybody that's there
it's it's like a big giant
family reunion that goes good that
wasn't forever
you go bad family reunion
and then when trump comes in to speak
it's just like
music to your ears i thought i saw heads
turn i thought maybe the
air was coming in no but it's just music
to your ears because he's
for the first time we've heard a
politician speak
and say i'm going to do this this and
this
bet your ass i'm going to do it and you
know what
he doesn't we we don't get that in
politicians they just don't do that
janine said love his dancing a lot of
people like that when he dances a lot of
people
like that apparently he's got the dance
is starting to evolve
with him yeah it is it's starting to get
more
like more of the shoulders and the arms
and yeah i saw that
they keep zooming in as if he's gonna
walk right around that corner but i'm
not
my favorite is when they leave people
out in the cold you know
we live in an imperfect world accidents
happen
uh logistics nightmare when you have 10
20 30 000 people you're bound to have an
accident
somewhere somehow god bless each and
every one of them
to get back home nice and safe
well trump um some are uh but
uh there are some that have been sent to
the hospital
um a few hypothermia so we are praying
for them
we are praying for those that out there
and like brian said
it's not i mean honestly i i don't even
know where the fault
of this is on i don't know whether it's
the state or whether
the trump campaign is supposed to be
doing this because
um somebody has to be providing the
transportation so
i think it's local buses he came to i'm
not going to mention what city but he
came to one of my local cities
and it was the actual buses from the
city
they were like service well
i can't say it because then it'll give
away what time and i don't want to do
that
but yeah we have like a specific i don't
want to do that it's too small
but we have like specific uh buses here
and those are the buses that bus
the people from the airport down and
back up so
it was on a local level you really think
trump is trump in the trump campaign's
in charge right of the
boxes right right hold on and they plan
that out to screw
people no and and here's my thing and
this might sound
crass to all the democrats out there all
the liberals
uh i think a lot of conservatives will
agree with me on this if you're gonna go
somewhere ex plan for the worst you're
in the middle of like the coldest state
it's going to be -4 and wind chills of
30. you know that because you looked at
the weather before you went to the trump
rally
prepare well gee what if the buses would
break down what if someone would attack
the buses and we couldn't get back
you know put yourself in that situation
you have to be prepared and just know
well i went outside and stood in the
freezing cold for eight hours
not a surprise this could happen right
and i will say
in kenosha wisconsin right now the
temperature is 46 degrees
and in about another hour or so it's
going to get down to 40
44 with the winds blowing at 10 miles an
hour
i just think it's funny because there's
been there has been tons of times where
i've been to concerts or football games
in freezing cold weather and the buses
didn't show up
and screwed up my schedule and i was
freezing cold and i complained about it
i don't see anybody it didn't make
headline news
that i was at a steeler game and and
froze
and the buses didn't come right so
therefore you know
it made ben roethlisberger look bad in
the rest of the town no i don't think so
it's just liberals looking to blame
something else on trump to try to get
him to lose votes
and it's not going to work so just save
your fingers from the typing
it doesn't work right go to a football
game
in wisconsin up there in green bay
during the winter screw that i did it
one time
i mean invisible it was a middle of the
afternoon and the sun was out
and it was miserable because it was
so freaking cold and the wind was
blowing and everybody was drunk at
noon and it just wait hold on i don't
know how you don't do it up there
you just messed up because when you're
drunk you're already warm
so that's oh cause i wasn't i wasn't
doing what i supposed to be
but y'all up there in green bay y'all
another
y'all whole another set of people close
yeah i think he's close i see those suvs
we were talking about brian
yeah boy he was supposed to come on i
wonder why he's late where was his last
rally was it later
uh nine o'clock i mean it's nine o'clock
he's supposed to be back on at 10 30.
there's no way
no no no no he did add
he added one more last night super late
uh i think he wound up in florida last
night
11 12. yeah 11 o'clock he and he went
past
curfew and that was great because they
were all chanting open it up
open it up uh he went he was like until
close to one o'clock i think
he just keeps going and going clinton
said his team's the vikings he
understands but they
this underscore guy 420 yes he does have
another rally tonight
yes he does now that's a good question
this guy 420 um
is this his last one ever the one
tomorrow or the one uh
next coming up will that be his last
round yep
yep tonight because he's not a rally on
the day of the election
because everybody needs to be out voting
yeah yeah this is the last one ever
pinch yourself
you know i mean maybe he'll give rallies
in two years you know
2022 i would hope he just does like uh
i mean i'm sure he will like a thank you
rally like hey i'm gonna come i'm gonna
do like a thank you tour
like blank amount of states just to do
some rallies just
for me i want yeah he did last time
after he won yeah so yeah yeah
definitely but uh 2022 candidates for
for uh congress and spent whoever's
running i'm sure he's going to be in
those states helping those out so we
don't have a debacle like we did in 2018
and lose the house
so yeah there's one more rally tonight
that will be his last one
maybe his last one ever yeah
that's interesting well
at least for real no you know because
he will be the standard bearer remember
he's in charge of the republican
party now we mean for reelection his
last one for re-election
right but yeah but he's going to be
out there for years to come given
addresses at the republican national
convention
and also promoting
the next republican you know what i
didn't think about that
um i've always said that the republican
party is going to have to find somebody
that's closer to
donald trump in the future if they want
to win the future elections
if he has anything to say with it or if
he has anything to do with it they will
right i don't think that he's going to
uh
let uh uh
an establishment person come on back in
there before he hits the stage
let uh hopefully this happens tomorrow
hopefully there's a lot of this
that is still out there that happens
tomorrow i'm a longtime democrat more
enraged
but when you listen to both these
parties talk i have made up my mind
i am definitely gonna go for you know uh
donald trump i come from a long line of
democrats
but i have to say i switched parties i
used to be a democrat i am now
republican voting republican all the way
no longer a democrat they are they are
communist
they're socialists candidly i was a
hillary voter and so for me i
i bought into a lot of stereotypes about
him a lifelong democrat i'm from la reno
ohio i am definitely changing my vote to
republicans
i've been a registered democrat for many
years
and this is um done i'm a democrat i'm
from minnesota
where all these riots and looting and
the burning started
i mean not a mention about us last week
i want america to stay a place that is
free that is
pro-business but you still consider
yourself a democrat
i will be changing that
leah armando says
how can pennsylvania even be close media
really hates
americans yeah
the media really does hate america i
don't understand how pennsylvania can be
close and here's why
armando uh he joe biden said
that he was going to stop fracking he
said he was going to ruin the oil
industry
and pennsylvania does not want that
and i can tell you suburban women in
pennsylvania do not want to defund the
police
because we have a huge state police
department
huge in pennsylvania you have to realize
it stretches
for miles you know how like you all have
local police departments right
well we don't because we have such small
little towns everywhere
you get the state police that come out
uh-huh yeah so like when i call police
here at my house
i don't have a local police station the
state police come out
they have state police barracks every 15
miles
wow and a lot of women suburban women
are married to these men
one of my old best friends lost their
husband to a shooting
that that played out almost the exact
same way that everything else has been
playing out
and he was a police officer shot him
right in the head and died
and it was so hurtful and you wouldn't
believe how much this community has
has came together when that happened and
i can tell you suburban women in
pennsylvania a lot of them are married
to police
and this is the last thing they want and
i'll tell you one other thing
philadelphia to pittsburgh to erie
to way down down in uh
i guess you could say all the mothers
all the sperm women want their kids to
go back to school they do not
want their kids to not to be in virtual
school anymore i'm telling you the whole
state
and that is why i'm positive he is going
to win pennsylvania
unless there's a cheat if he's gonna
beat the cheat i don't know
watch uh florida georgia
ohio and pennsylvania and it's just
gonna happen
just like that wisconsin mission
typically
right just like that and i'm telling you
minnesota
you don't think minnesota yes i'm i'm
calling it i'm just saying this is going
to be the biggest shock in all
and their only response is going to be
there has to be some kind of cheating
within the trump campaign and real quick
when florida goes red when florida
starts to sway red
it takes those east coast states with it
pennsylvania
it takes with it it takes ohio with it
so florida's starting to go red it's
going to take those other red
swing states with it watch and see it
has happened for last 20 years
yeah no republican president ever did it
without ohio
you're saying these are the key states
we're talking about right oh yeah
boom boom and they're gonna fall like
dominoes
there he is well just in case it doesn't
ladies and gentlemen
uh just be prepared if it
doesn't that trump can still win
any manner of ways even if it doesn't
because some people are saying that it's
going to be a landslide i've always said
it was going to be close
yeah it's going to be close even before
we got on
even even before we started doing this
again i always said i was gonna
be close because joe biden wasn't bernie
sanders or whatnot so
but i still thought that president trump
was gonna win
um but now i hope that it's not close
i don't want it to be close and
president trump is ready to speak
so and make sure that the music is not
wait your lips start moving yeah that's
true
there you go wait no
no no oh no
kenosha it's nice to be back it's nice
to be back
we spent a little time with you a little
law and order we brought
law and order to kenosha
right that's what we want and hello
wisconsin big day tomorrow big big day
big day and i think we're going to do
very well in wisconsin just like we did
four years ago
and it's an honor to be with you
thank you
and this is a lot of people this is a
lot of people
see you know what that means he's
getting feedback wouldn't have to pay
for the microphones because they did a
bad job
tomorrow we are going to win this day
and we are going to win
four more years in the white house
and with your vote we will continue to
cut your taxes cut regulations
support our police support our great
military
protect your second amendment that's
under siege but don't worry about it
unless sleepy joe got in then you can
forget about your second amendment
defend religious liberty and ensure more
products are proudly stamped
with that beautiful phrase made in the
usa
next year we will be and you know we're
going to be together next year
we're going to be together for four more
years and we're going to be together
forever because we're doing things that
nobody's
ever done and we're doing them together
and it was my pleasure to be with you a
number of months ago when
when you had that you were in the news
right you were in the news
are they saying turn it up yeah i don't
think some people are
hearing him way wearing the bag this
year will be the greatest economic year
in the history of our country
and i hope you can hear can you hear
back there by the way
oh this is crap man they can't hear them
that's
right they're getting the feedback
because they're trying to turn it up
okay that was the problem you gotta get
the microphone
he is not happy though i mean he's
running late he wants to be on time he
wants to get this thing done
and get on to the next one and this
should have already been
it's a microphone i mean middle
schoolers
didn't work a microphone this is
ridiculous what's wrong here how's that
is that getting better
and then we're supposed to pay these
people right now
is that better come on
okay we'll do this
improvise you know sometimes
which is better this one or
this one which one
this one is that better can you hear
this could be a very uncomfortable
evening for me
all right we'll figure oh my gosh he's
holding it
good job fellas i'm always saying i want
a perfect bike good job
good job on the mic check there uh buddy
this is the first time i've ever used a
handheld um
an hour two hours three hours
now we have one more tonight after this
grand rapids where we finish up at grand
rapids
and uh we finished up there four years
ago
and a little bit superstitious let's do
it the same way we came here we came to
grand rapids
let's keep it going and i hope everyone
can hear me now yes
yeah all the way back there all the way
back good you let me know you're not
you're not shy i was wondering everyone
should i thought they didn't like me i
was saying
i'm not sure i said what's going on over
here right
thank you very much so wonder my
leadership our economy is now
growing at the fastest rate ever
recorded
33.1 fastest ever recorded
we created a record 11.4 million jobs in
the last five months that's a
record and while foreign nations are in
free fall we are creating an economic
powerhouse
unrivaled anywhere in the world a recent
gallup poll found that 56 percent of
americans
say they're better off today than they
were
four years ago that's
under the auspices of barack hussein
obama
and sleepy joe biden
you're not going to want to have joe
biden you know if we had uh
see the media look at all the media back
there if we had if they had a cover
if they had to cover him for two months
and say
we have to bring the president back we
have to bring
we have to bring trump back they would
be out of business
they would be out of business if biden
harris and the radical left gain power
they will collapse our economy and send
your nation this wonderful nation
into a depression that was is what
you know they want this is the only guy
i've ever seen who runs by saying
we will he doesn't say it like that he
goes
we will raise your taxes i never heard
that before
you know i've covered politicians i've
been friends of politicians
i've been enemies also but i've never
seen somebody saying
we will raise your taxes they want to
give you the largest tax increase in the
history of our country and we can't let
that happen
we can't let that happen so get out and
vote tomorrow's the biggest
tomorrow will be i think will be the
most important
election in the history of our country
and i never thought i'd say that
i never thought i'd say it so get out
and vote
sleepy joe biden will raise your taxes
four trillion dollars
massively increase your regulations shut
down your farms
close down your factories how's he doing
so far
send your jobs over they start bullying
them
i don't know is this guy really big but
i mean is
should he really win are we serious
about this
what the hell is going on is he serious
guy has no clue he's shot some people
are shot he's shot
did you see him today with the uh the
aviators right the glasses right came on
very tough he's very agitated you know
it's like
sort of like going crazy i think destroy
the suburbs dissolve your borders
terminate religious liberty
outlaw private healthcare confiscate
your gun second amendment is in deep
trouble
not with me it's not it hasn't you
notice it hasn't been touched right
it hasn't been touched you think that
was easy it wasn't easy
and indoctrinate your children with
anti-american lies
so i just signed an executive order to
teach our students pro-american values
biden has vowed to abolish the american
oil and natural gas industries and ban
fracking now from your standpoint you
don't like it because you don't want
energy costs going up right that's what
he do
biden's energy band will send every
state into
crushing poverty from wisconsin to
michigan nevada pennsylvania
as long as i am president will remain
the number one producer of oil
and natural gas in the world and we are
right now
they're a low energy crowd compared to
florida last night and we will remain
energy independent you know we're energy
independent we don't need foreign
nations anymore
but we have good relationships in the
middle east you know we're
we're doing peace in the middle east you
believe it no blood in the sand
peace in the middle east
joe biden is a globalist who spent 47
years
outsourcing your jobs opening your
borders and sacrificing american blood
and treasure
on foreign wars you know what they call
them the endless
foreign wars countries that many of you
have never heard about
what
do you still have that mike
what's going on
i don't know i think we're doing fine
with this mic brad i don't want to put
this guy under pressure
you're on stage you got 27 000 people
watching you don't get nervous
don't worry because he's a professional
i'll give you the name of his company
never use that company oh you want to
just put it in there well that's
is it the same mic as the other one it's
a different mic
that means that one's supposed to be
better right uh
that's not good
okay we'll take that sucker out of there
right congratulations
oh my god
how's he doing he's got a mask on you
can't even see him
wow what a cluster
snafu that's a term we used in the
military
situation normal all right now we're
back when we started
oh my god right back before we started
okay okay
you know what i won't pay the bill of
the you know company that this is
crazy microphone and they'll do a story
trump is a
horrible human being it isn't payable no
i don't like to pay bills when people do
a bad job you don't either but
i don't know they look like nice people
they come from kenosha so i'm going to
pay the bill anyway what the hell
the water and i wear the red tie they're
sort of expensive and
you know you don't like to spill water
on the red tie right
so sometimes i'll use two hands and
because i want to catch the water
because i want to save the tide because
i'm basically cheap you know
so i'll take the water and i'll go like
this and i'll take a little zip
and they'll say there's something wrong
with him there's something
there so now i'm trying to so i go like
this
so now by holding a mic all night long
like this you're going to say well
there's nothing wrong with that right
hand or like that
now did you ever hear that there's
something wrong you can't lift a glass
of water and i have no problem
with that something he's right about
he's right about
saving the time biden was a cheerleader
for nafta
and china's entry into the world trade
organization
wisconsin lost half of your manufacture
think of it
you lost half of your manufacturing jobs
after the betrayals these were betrayals
by a lot of people
and biden was one of them he's a corrupt
politician and he sold out
wisconsin to china but he's a corrupt
politician
and these people never told you that and
they don't want to write about it
and big tech doesn't want to talk about
it and it's off bounds
and they're not allowed to talk and we
have suppression
we have suppression this is a media
suppression
the likes of which nobody has ever seen
and if you take a look you've never seen
anything like
it the last famous last words
but nobody's ever seen anything like it
you know his
son walks in his son had no job he left
the military unfortunately it wasn't
good
and then what happens is the father
becomes vice president
and this kid becomes like a human vacuum
cleaner
he follows the father into countries dad
who are you going to today well let's go
to
china and he's a vacuum cleaner follows
the father takes in money right it's
terrible
they give him one and a half billion
dollars one and a half million
wanted to think of it one and a half
billion dollars
and he gets fees off that millions of
dollars a year
there's only one problem he has no
experience investing money
they give him the money they gave him
the money after 10 minutes i think our
congress has to take a look at that what
do you think fellas
i think you're gonna have to look at it
can you imagine you know i have a lot of
my kids here tonight can you imagine if
my kids said
yeah dad i got a billion and a half
dollars from china
oh i don't think they'd want to write
about that the fake news do you think
they'd write about that
then he gets three and a half million
dollars from
the mayor of moscow's wife right what
did he get that for
remember i asked that at the debate the
first debate i said it
chris wallace thought it was an
inappropriate question really i think
you think
chris wallace now i must tell you
i think kristin did a better job krista
welker right
i don't mean she was perfect actually
some people said she wasn't ray verness
i thought she was nice
relatively speaking she was great for
what i get
how about the one savannah guthrie you
see that one that was
that was another beautiful live at nine
o'clock she's jumping out of a chair
she's like going crazy
but we all do well you know i don't get
questions like he gets
he gets sir uh what kind of ice cream
are you eating did you see that
they never asked me questions like that
in 2016 wisconsin
voted to fire this corrupt it and really
it's like
corrupt corrupt political establishment
right
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally putting
america first and finally putting
america forward
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician right
if i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and nobody has ever
fought harder for you than i am
i will tell you nobody that's why they
hating
when the violent mob came to kenosha
biden opposed
sending in the national guard of course
you remember this right
he did he didn't want to send in the
guard he thought it was
terrible descendant of the gun and we
sent in the guard
and we saved kenosha we said
i said you know i think kenosha's gonna
like me we did a good job
i wish they sent him in a little bit
earlier right if we had him in a little
bit earlier but that's okay
that's okay but we sent in and how good
did the guard do though did we do the
job did they do they do
barden and kamala does anybody know who
kamala is that's
this wonderful woman she wants to be
your first
female president i don't think so i
don't think so
you know that's a good reason not to
vote for sleepy joe too right you don't
want to do that
you want to have we all want to see that
happen someday but we don't want this to
be the one right
but they're waging war on our police you
know that your police would
we have a lot of police here tonight i
recognize it because
because i went and i met all of the
police i met a lot of great police
federal police i met the whole group
and you have great police
i agree with that but i stand with the
heroes of law enforcement and i was
honored to be endorsed by
kenosha county sheriff david beth thank
you david wherever you may be
thank you david that was so nice that
was so nice
they like you out there david that's
very good appreciate it david thank you
very much
and as i'm sure you've heard biden's far
left supporters
are threatening to loot and riot
tomorrow
if they don't get their way up there
i'll get their way
are we all ready david everybody ready
uh towards uh
if they know we're ready and if they
know we're not playing games they won't
even be here they won't show up
you know it's like i brought an old law
into existence
when i saw them going around all over
the country knocking down statues right
and monuments
and we signed we brought it in and i
signed it updated and signed it
ten years in prison have you knocked
down a statue or monument
and you don't see it anymore they look
and they say oh we'd like to knock that
one down but you know what 10 years
is too much darling let's leave now
this is yet more evidence why the
radical f cannot be trusted with power
we strongly condemn political violence
we
condemn it and we condemn it strongly
biden must
tell his supporters he doesn't really
have supporters let's face it
doesn't have supporters the guy's shot
he doesn't have
this there's an ideology that has
supporters
and he's just a vessel you know he
happened to be the one that got through
because
elizabeth warren instead of getting out
like she should have and letting bernie
take it that's so funny
bernie he he is a great loser he really
is he's we need thanks
guys when he says shot he's talking
about right over here
but biden ended up being there biden
ended up being there and
that's the way it is that he has to tell
his supporters and i think you're going
to see something
look at the people over here they go oh
hello can you actually hear this can you
hear this
because this is the worst microphone
i've ever used in my life can you
actually hear me on that
not the microphone all the way back
that's good thank you i can't believe it
it sounds terrible to me
his silence is that it doesn't sound
great right to me it doesn't suck
it's all right good you know what keep
saying it
that bill he says don't pay him don't
pay him
he hear that johnny don't pay the damn
bill when you please a piece of garbage
i gave
it's not even the first right back the
one the good one is
is it's put to rest you know this is
going to be headline news tomorrow
that's all they're going to talk about
donald trump and his failures including
the striker
roman james
and you're gonna have a day tomorrow the
likes of which i think people haven't
seen in a long time
you're gonna have a red way it's gonna
be a beautiful sight
and you know what we have a lot of we
have we actually have a country that
outside of a
radical group and this is a radical
group
but we have a country that's very well
united when you look at a group of
people like this it's incredible
and i go from here i go i tell you grand
rapids
we have they say they have 40 50 000
people in grand rapids
last night in florida we had 45 000
people
no problem everybody's in love
everybody loves our country it's a
beautiful thing i'm telling you this
there's a lot of unity we just don't
complain you know we don't complain
we just go out and do what we have to do
but you know when we were having that
incredible run we were doing the best
and now we're almost at that same point
and we'll be there soon
but our country was uniting we were
getting calls
we had the best employment numbers ever
african-american asian-american
hispanic-american
and we were getting calls like yeah
maybe it's time we get together you know
because success brings people together
success brings people together and
you're going to see that happening
because we're having numbers the likes
of which we've never had before
33 think of it 33.1 nobody's ever had
that
the highest was 1952 and it was less
than half of that number
so rioting looting an arson will be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law i'm just telling you that right now
i'm telling you that right now that if
people are you know i hate to see where
they put boards up on a window this
shouldn't be that
it shouldn't be that but we are going we
are a country of law and order we have
to be
we are and people and you notice i hate
to say it and but it's true
this is a these are democrat mayors and
governors these are democrat-run cities
and states
they're the ones if you look at new york
and chicago
and how about portland which is
anarchist we could solve that problem we
tell the governor
you want us to solve the problem we
solve it in 30 minutes
we solved it in seattle we went in we
were going to go in the morning we
announced we're going in in the morning
and they just raised their hands and
they left
the night before and we did a great job
in uh
you know minneapolis we did a great job
we're gonna win minnesota for two
reasons we did a great job
now they could have called they could
have let us do it a week and a half
early that would have been nice you know
right so that the announcer remember the
anchor you looked over he says this is a
peaceful protest
thank you what a group what a group
what a group i've gotten to know the
state very well
you know you surprised you know you're
the one that put us over the top you
know that right remember
we were waiting for pennsylvania four
years ago we're waiting for pennsylvania
they didn't want to call it oh they were
going crazy i remember that
they were crying you know what the hell
was happening
this will be a very short evening for
donald trump
four years ago right and they were just
little they were looking forward
remember the woman crying in the
convention center that beautiful
remember the woman he was going crazy
glasses
her head's got she was she's i wonder
where she is right now she's
you put her away no no this was not a
person that i was easily
going to convince to be on my side i
think she was going crazy but remember
at the beginning they show everyone's
happy everyone's thrilled
they spent a fortune it was one of the
most beautiful
things i've ever seen in terms of a
stage they had it shaped like the united
states
hello back there are you okay
but that was a hell of an evening and
this evening is going to be i'm telling
you tomorrow
it's going to be i can't say bigger
there was was there ever anything as big
i'll tell you the election is more
important
but the evening will be as good or
almost as good and that's okay too but
that was the first
right that was the first that was
something you think
yeah that was some evening he won
florida he won ohio he won it all
thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you very much
and because of the microphone we are
giving you back half of your admission
price
but considering that you paid nothing
i'm sorry you're getting
it the price is right nah
it's fine but you know but wasn't that
something though where they say
uh the evening begins and they say this
is going to be very quick
you know what happened they did exit
polls and a lot of the people said
none of your business oh who did you
vote for none of your business
that meant trump and they did 44 percent
you know that 44 of the people said none
of your business and that meant job
they call it the none of your business
vote
but almost all of them i think maybe all
of them were trump
so they didn't count them so they said
oh this is going to be a blowout tonight
but they didn't realize you know these
pulses haven't been doing so good with
me
and uh we blew it out it was incredible
it started
with ohio remember we're going to do
great in ohio tomorrow too by the way
great oh the numbers are good
donald trump has won the state of ohio
that's a big state
you know i heard for a year while we're
doing this you cannot win
unless you win the state of ohio every
night they did it
and then all of a sudden poll numbers
started coming out that i was leading in
a while
but anyway but they thought i was going
to win by one point i won by eight
they said he won ohio he won by eight
points what the hell is going on here
that's a lot
and then they said oh no
please don't tell me this donald trump
has won the state of florida no no no
no please i held that one out for a long
time
please remember martha raddatz abc oh my
god oh please
please don't tell me this oh no i'm a
neutral i'm
i'm very neutral i don't know please
martha neutral please the tears swipe
them away
quickly no then we won florida then we
won
georgia then we went south carolina then
we won the firewall was remembered in
north carolina
that's their firewall we are going to
win north carolina they have they put so
much money into north carolina
but uh we had an asset from north
carolina named
lara lara lara
trump married to
married to the legendary eric trump
where are you are you two there
we had a we had a big asset there laura
trump and
she knew that area so well and they
loved her so much
they loved her so much and they just had
another baby and they named
the baby carolina they named the baby
carolina
and i i tell you though but i i said we
have to give south carolina some
credit too for that
bring them up come on up get over there
come on
bring them up break them up
great come on come on
tell you what wayne this one
they love her and north carolina
you guys feel like this crowd is lacking
and they love her in wisconsin too
i'm done now apparently wisconsin
who here is ready for four more years
a vote for donald trump is a vote for
freedom
a vote for donald trump is a voice vote
for the future
a vote for donald trump is a vote for
god
and a vote for donald trump is a vote
for america
how do you guys feel are we gonna win
wisconsin
let's go do this a second time thank you
man they're really pointing the mics
away from the people
they do not want the people that's
cheering to be heard
no it's like so lackluster they're all
no the people are cheering they're just
not pulling the bikes out
like a family reunion today
now well you know this is now the big
time because tomorrow's the big day
and uh we have one more stop see
actually you know i did five today but
i could say i could say i did six
because
in miami we finished it close to two
o'clock in the morning
six today okay after grand rapids
joe biden is bought and paid for by big
tech
big media and powerful special interests
you know that
they own him they control him and they
know he will always do their bidding
and when he raises 300 million dollars
for this campaign
in a short period of time ask him what
deals did you have to make because i
would be the greatest fundraiser of all
time
i can call the wall street guys i know
them all i could say
send me 25 million dollars immediately
please yes sir mr president
i will but you know once you do that you
totally compromise you can't do anything
properly
once you do that and i say i don't want
to do that
and we we did very well with the
fundraising stuff but a lot of it came
in small donations
first time a republican has ever raised
a lot of money with small donations like
61 average or something like that
every corrupt force in american life has
betrayed you
and hurt you and they're all supported
by
joe biden the failed establishment that
started the disastrous
foreign wars they're supported by sleepy
joe biden
the career politicians that offshored
your industries
and you had plenty offshore and
decimated your factories
they support joe biden the open borders
lobbyists all the people that killed our
fellow citizens with
illegal drugs gangs and crime and you
know a lot about that
they support joe biden the anti-american
radicals defaming our noble history
heritage and heroes
they support joe biden that's cancel
culture we don't believe in cancer
culture do we
antifa and the writers and looters and
marxists and left-wing extremists
they all support biden
this election comes down to a simple
choice
do you want to be ruled by the corrupt
and selfish political class
or do you want to be governed by the
american people it's what it's all about
it's the american people
they've taken that away they've taken it
away
and what's going on with big tech and
what's going on with the media
is nobody has ever seen anything like it
there's never been anything like it
nobody has seen anything like it
where you know you can't have a side you
can't have
you can't have a scandal if there's
nothing written about it it's pretty
dumb
a vote for biden is a vote to give
control of government over to the
globalists and communists and socialists
and
wealthy liberal hypocrites
hypocrites who want to silence censor
cancel and punish you these are a real
real trouble if you want your children
to be safe if you want your values to be
respected if you want your
if you want to be just treated with
dignity and respect
then i am asking you tomorrow to go out
and vote for your all-time favorite
president
because we still have work to do
thank you
remember what i said four years ago i
am your voice and we will all together
make america great again that's what
we're doing it's what we've done
for the last four years the depraved
swamp has tried everything to stop me
can you imagine if they didn't do the
hoax the russia russia hoax right russia
russia russia
how about shift getting up the other day
the laptop from hell
right that's where's hunter where's
hunter is hunting
where is hunter oh he's in a country i
say his father just left the country
he's gonna scam them for a couple of
months
where is hunter no but he's got the
laptop
from hell and shift got up with the
watermelon head right like a watermelon
and he goes
this was produced by russia
these people are crazy aren't they hey
watermelon what a crazy bunch but they
know
i don't answer to them my answer to you
it's true i'd look i didn't need this
i didn't need this i had a very nice
life
i had a very nice life but you know what
it's the greatest thing i ever did
because
no administration no president in the
first three and a half years
the biggest tax cut in history the
biggest regulation
cuts rebuilding our military
look at what we've done look at what
we've done our vets just gave a 91
approval rating the highest in history
the highest in history now look at what
we've done space force i never even
talked about space force
i never talked i i realized we needed it
after i was in office i looked i saw
i saw russia i saw china i said we need
space force
first time in 74 years new one right a
new one right congressman
we did uh we did a great job on it
together we will defeat the corrupt
establishment we will dethrone the
failed
political class we will drain the
washington swamp
and we will save the american
dream a dream for your children your
grandchildren right
a dream for your children and your
grandchildren
we have the energy and the people to
prove the corrupt media wrong
and that's what we have we have an
energy like no
movement has ever had in this country
you know somebody would go in and do
well in new hampshire as an example i'm
thinking about one because i have a lot
of respect for
he did what came in second in a primary
and he became famous for many years
what we did is we won all the primaries
we won everything and then we won the
presidency
no there's never been a movement like
this and now
they go after us illegally they spied on
our campaign our campaign is not my
our campaign they tried to
take out a duly elected president of the
united states and we caught them
and we caught them and let's see what
happens to them
and you know who is a part of it barack
hussein obama
and sleepy joe biden
and plenty of others like comey etc but
plenty of others but they were a part of
it
so now we'll see what happens right
we're going to see
we're going to see what happens so but
you have to get out and vote this is the
biggest thing get out and vote
who by the way who's already voted you
know i thought so
but we have a tendency to vote on
election day at republicans so
let me ask you who is planning to vote
tomorrow
but very important that was louder that
was louder
is anybody planning to vote for sleepy
joe biden please your ass yeah
does anybody have the courage to raise
you
well that's good that's a lot of people
so a lot of you vote a little bit early
then
do you trust the ballot system do you do
early voting or do you do the ballot
early i like early but early is good
early is good ballad is not good we got
a very
horrible horrible ruling from the
supreme court of the united states
a ruling that puts our country in danger
actually
on pennsylvania they have so much time
to do this thing oh
let them put their votes in and give
them plenty of time
you know we have a date it's called
november 3rd we don't have a date that
says
many days later we don't have a date
that says you're allowed to
go and start you know putting your vote
in later and we can tabulate it later
take your time
the whole world is waiting to find out
and there's great danger in that number
one there's danger that
there's a lot of shenanigans that go on
from that time forth there's a lot of
shenanigans
and then there's a lot of bad things
that can happen with
with the streets i mean you're gonna
have a population
that's going to be very very angry and
you just can't do that
that is such a dangerous decision that
is such a disappointment when i heard
that decision
that's a terrible decision just you go
take a look at it and i know you people
are taking a look at it
but there's not a decision that i've
ever heard of like that
where people if you want to put your
ballot in and if you want to
you go and you put it in two or three or
four weeks early
you're not going but yeah he said you
had a whole year you had a lot of time
you had a lot of time so they say oh
this is so terrible you know
they gave them extra time and then all
the time so now they're we're going to
be all waiting around because
pennsylvania we're going to win
pennsylvania it's a great
state but you know it's like you it's in
a total shutdown they shut it down the
governor is a democrat he shut it down
it'll probably open on the fourth it'll
open up he'll announce ladies and
gentlemen now that the election is over
we're going to open it up right
but you can't do that that's a very very
dangerous decision by the supreme court
i guess it was a political decision i
don't know what it was
i don't know what they were thinking and
you know what maybe
i should maybe i shouldn't be speaking
this way i'm very disappointed on behalf
of this country that a thing like this
can happen
because we could be waiting for weeks
before we ever find out
what's going on the whole world is
waiting for this decision
it's a very sad it's a very sad thing
and hopefully it's going to be changed
hopefully their wisdom and they have
wisdom
hopefully their wisdom will prevail and
they'll do something and
lawyers will be going in and they'll be
fighting and you know but
people in fact it's all over television
tonight i'm coming from
place to place and i'm the good thing
about air force one it's got more
televisions and
any hotel room in the world okay you
have them on the floors you have them on
the ceilings
you have them all over and you see the
the comments that are being made about
the decision that
some of the pros are saying this is a
very dangerous decision for our country
because so many things i mean they're
going to say well how many votes short
are we
we need 6 000 votes well let's take 6
000 of these
we'll put them over here let's take 6
it's gonna be cheating it's going to be
cheating it's like
they're putting these people and you
know what we don't consider the people
that have been running elections in
philadelphia to be very honest we've had
a lot of problems with philadelphia
so that's the story and hopefully
that'll be changed and
i'm sure the people would say oh you
shouldn't speak that way about the
supreme court
we've had so many bad decisions out of
the supreme court that i will speak that
way and that's the way it is this
election
is also a choice between a deadly biden
lockdown
and a safe vaccine that ends and by the
way we're rounding the turn anyway but
we have great vaccines
we have great vaccines coming we have
great vaccines coming and it's a lot of
good things are happening and
you know when you look at the
therapeutics excuse me
i'm right here no i don't think the
therapeutic
helped me i don't think i needed it i'm
glad i got it right regeneron we're
going to make it available
free to anybody that needs it we're
making it available free
to anybody that needs it free but i'll
tell you what i'm joined in because i'm
you know i'm a perfect physical specimen
and i am considered very very young i'm
considered young for my age
no i'm a perfect specimen i'm in perfect
shape
so i'm sure i would have thrown it away
but uh no but i had it and the next
morning i was not feeling good at all i
tell you
the doctor said sir i hate to say it
you've just tested positive i said
doc sean a great doctor
white house doctor i said sean tell me
what does that mean test it positive for
what
sir you've tested positive for the kind
of plague you know
he used it much nicer than he said coven
he said coven you know it's got about 37
names you know that we could name it i
always like to have a china in there
because i like to be accurate
but but he said sir you've tested
positive for coma i said i'm in the
middle of the campaign i can't be
positive for covert
and uh so anyway so i was and i didn't
feel too good
and the first lady had it at least now
you know that all those rumors is that
she lives in virginia separate i mean
at least now you know she lives in the
white house
because she got it probably for me or
whatever i don't know what the hell
you know do you ever hear the first lady
lives in virginia in a beautiful house
over a river or something
no no she lives here but at least that
and then
i know people love the first lady they
love them
they love the first lady it's true they
love her she's doing a good job
they love that whole family back there
they love that family back there
great family hi tiffany
so so then so melania has it but she
knocked it out
pretty good and i i did a great job you
know i was surrounded by these doctors
12 doctors i've told this story each one
was a specialist
johns hopkins walter reed medical center
is incredible you know that's our
military center it's incredible
and i'm surrounded right i'm just
surrounded by these brilliant doctors
one thing when you're president you get
a lot of doctors and each doctor grabbed
a different part of my body
and i said i don't like this at all but
they told me about this one thing and i
said i really do i like it i really but
it was
very you know a little bit early what
we've done with getting it through the
fda has been incredible biden wouldn't
have this stuff done for
years but we had his chance with a swine
flu and totally blew it right
it was a disaster it was a disaster
anyway so i wake up the next morning
and i'm telling you i felt like superman
i was so i wanted to get out
i said give me another trade deal to
renegotiate that these
clowns have screwed up give me a trade
deal to renegotiate and where am i
supposed to be well sir could you take
it easy for a couple of days
people are sort of amazed i've done
these things i mean i do them these
are not easy to do especially when you
have no damn microphone i mean
i'm working harder on this one than i
have on all six that i did today
this is the hardest one
because i have a microphone that was
obviously meant for congressmen and
senators
not for a president so it's a little bit
off
but that's okay you know you have to
learn how to imp isn't that funny when
you put it back in here and hand it to
me
but that's the way we started i thought
that was better nobody got that only
this front row got that one
i thought that was very clever actually
but then he came up to me the doctor
sean he said sir
i'm sorry to inform you that your son
baron has tested positive
again i said brilliantly for what
he said for covet i said oh that's
terrible
oh no he'll be okay sir he'll be okay i
said it's terrible
but he's young and he's strong and he's
very tall have you ever seen i said
hi barrett 14 years old he's very tall
he's
he's definitely tall and he's strong but
he's young
and i said that sir we said no he'll be
okay sir he'll be okay
and i said well i hope like 12 minutes
later i'd say how's baron doing doctor
sarah he's 100 now he's
get your kids back to school okay
right get them back to school
all right so we're gonna mass distribute
the vaccine in just a few short weeks
it's going to be coming out very soon
and we will quickly eradicate the virus
wipe out the china plague once and for
all get it the hell out of here
we will never forget either we will not
forget that was not good you know we
made a great trade deal with china as
you know very well
but you know the ink wasn't dry before
we got this
and no good no good joe biden is
promising to delay the vaccine and turn
america into a prison state
locking you in your home while you're
your far left anarchists are allowed to
roam the streets burn down your cities
hit people over the head they're allowed
to do that
that's why i always call all of these
rallies protests these are not rallies
anymore
because you're allowed to have a protest
you can't have a rally and you can't go
to church
you know you're not allowed to go to
church but you're allowed to burn down
the cities with a protest so
we always call these friendly protests
divide and lock down will mean no school
no graduations no weddings no
thanksgiving
no christmas no easter no fourth of july
and no future
other than that it's really not a bad
way to go
a vote for sleepy joe biden is a vote
for lockdowns layoffs
misery and no fracking how about the guy
no fracking for over a year and a half
there will be no fracking he goes to
pennsylvania absolutely will frack
okay and these guys don't do anything
about it if you want a vaccine to kill
the virus
a job to support your family and freedom
to live your life
then you have no choice but to cast your
ballot
for a gentleman named donald j trump
and as i said and you have to remember
this you know because during the debate
the
debate was good thank you thank you very
much
thank you very much
thank you everybody it's a great honor
to be with you i really did during the
kenosha
disaster i really got to be friendly
with a lot of people up here long before
that because
we've had so many different people that
we deal with you have a few great people
we're going to introduce you a few of
them but you have great people here but
i really got to know you during that
problem that potential crisis that we
put out
very very swiftly once we got called and
uh
it's great you're great people you built
the country you're great people joe
biden
and as i said he ran the uh h1n1 he
called it n1h when he couldn't get it
right
he still does he can't get it right i
said joe h comes before n it's easy to
remember
h1n1 swine flu and he failed horribly
and he was a laughingstock all over
washington as you remember
his chief of staff i don't know why this
guy said it
but he made the worst statements he said
this guy we have no idea what we're
doing
now all of a sudden he's coming and he's
a he was the one that said
i i shouldn't close it down to china
heavily infected china right
you remember that mess anyway then now
he runs he said i should have closed it
sooner
it's uh it's really disgraceful
secretary of defense robert gates a
respected man
he said biden has been wrong on nearly
every
major foreign policy and national
security issue
over the past four years right
four years he said he's always wrong and
he has been always wrong
i don't believe he's even running i
can't believe the whole thing
i've watched i watched the debates you
had 27 total killers on the stage and he
was there and
but you don't have to believe me because
it's you
and because it's wisconsin we spent a
fortune and hopefully that'll work
better than the microphone try it put it
on
joe biden joe biden
why the hell would i take a test come on
man that's like saying you before you
got in this program you take a test
where you're taking cocaine or not what
do you think huh
are you a jones by the way it's my
little sister valerie and i'm jill's
husband
oh no oh you switched on me this is my
wife this is my sister
they switched over but i tell it if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or
trump and you ain't black there is not a
single solitary reason in the world
why why as i said we shouldn't be in a
position
that everybody and that's my wife chill
hey joey i'm jill's husband actually
and cornpop was a bad dude and he ran a
bunch of bad boys
and i did yeah he and back in those days
he shot things that changed
play the radio make sure the television
excuse me
make sure you have the record player on
at night the
default make sure the kids hear words we
need all these shoes to be self-evident
all men and women created me by the goal
you know the you know the thing
because if you could take care if you
were a quartermaster
you can sure help take care of running a
you know a department store
uh they were in the second
floor of the ladies department whatever
you know i mean well i'm sick and tired
of smart guys
you know the rapidly rising
in with with uh i don't know
there mendel caucus no you haven't
you're a lion dog face pony soldier
going to be uh we're going to be in a
different world we're live
after live after live after live
you know we have to come together that's
why i'm running
running is a proud democrat for the
senate
and by the way you know i sit on the
stand and it get hot i got a lot of i
got hairy legs
that turn that that that that that that
turn
uh um blonde in the sun and the kids
used to come up and reach into the pool
and rub my leg down so it was straight
and then watch the hair
come back up again they'd look at it so
i learned about roaches i learned about
kids jumping on my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap i
bet you rock and i think it's a right
for people who have bad account care we
have to do at least several things one
we have to uh depend on what the
president's going to do
right now and first of all he has to
tell uh wait till the cases before
anything happens
look exacerbating the need for example
confirms
environmental justice sorry as a bug
folks we got a lot of work to do
i don't need you to get me elected the
case we cannot let
this we've never allowed any crisis from
the civil war straight through to
the pandemic of 17 all the way around 16
we have never
never let our democracy
second fiddle way that we can both have
a democracy and
elections and at the same time direct to
public health
everywhere i've been hearing all around
the country you're trying your best
but it never feels like enough
and here comes the train that he tried
to make sure to continue
that's the commuter all right oh
no
oh
i am very willing to let the american
public
judge my physical mental film my
physical as well my mental
fitness i'll lead an effective strategy
to mobilize
true international pressure
oh joe is such a loser
really thank you they're gonna nail us
on that one
well there goes tonight's show yeah
that's it
i say from the pictures that dan scavino
is posting on twitter there's 25 to 30
thousand
people we have many more somewhere too
rough to put on we just decided
but that's look this is not what our
country needs this isn't
this isn't about yeah it is about me i
guess when you're thinking about it
but but this is not what our country can
have we can't have this
one thing i'll tell you i learned
president xi
of china president putin of russia
kim jong-un of north korea and many
others all of them
they're very sharp they're very smart
they're very sharp
he wasn't show up 25 years ago and now
it's not you can't let this happen to
our country that's all i can say
because it's not a game we're not
playing a game you know we have a good
time tonight we love each other we're
having fun but
when you get right there it's not about
fun we can't let this happen to our
country
joining us tonight speaking about
somebody that's great
is a senator who is my friend
he's my friend and he is a he just
doesn't stop
he's one of the sharpest toughest people
in washington
and he is on when he's on somebody that
person has no chance or that
bad group has no chance he's the head of
homeland
but he's a respected person and he's
your senator and we love him
and i'm telling you everybody in
washington talks about him in the
greatest of tones
senator ron johnson ron thank you
and he doesn't stop you talk about not
giving up
he doesn't stop and we have
brian style congressman great job great
job you're doing
thank you thank you very great job
you're doing
glenn grothman glenn thank you very much
great job glenn's doing a great job
darren lahood
baron good job darren what a good group
and you have a wonderful candidate who's
going to be
running and you know who that is he's
where is he where is jim jim jim
oberweis jim thank you jim
and i heard you're doing well glenn
how's he doing in the polls okay
he said he's gonna win when he says he's
gonna win he's gonna win too good
and i heard you're doing very well good
very good state gop
chair andrew hitt how we doing andrew
tomorrow good we're okay
because he's doing a nice job but if we
don't win he'll be fired immediately
and a friend of mine and a guy who's
done a terrific job he loves this state
kenosha's own reince priebus
where is he rides stand up right swears
right
what a nice what a good guy he is too
what a good guy
he's done took me years to learn how to
pronounce his name properly
but he's a fantastic person i'm
especially glad to be joined tonight
by don jr and kimberly and
don
come on up they're saying bring them up
uh oh come on you get john
talking this might never happen and he
loves to go out the hunt thing he
doesn't you don't have a jacket
if you catch a call he likes the
outdoors huh
you doing okay come on say something
hello wisconsin oh my god
or if i was joe biden i'd say florida
but
you know doesn't matter you don't have
to be right but
thank you guys thank you for the support
we've been seeing it on the ground
every day for weeks because without
guidance we don't have a mainstream
media that will campaign for us
would you say do
so we need you to get out and bring your
friends to vote
tomorrow and when we do we can not only
keep making america great again
but we can make liberals cry again get
out there and do it
wisconsin get out there and do it thank
you guys
don't give don't don't don't give a good
job
come on up i thought i thought i was
going to be the
only one but i was like no i felt the
same
i think jared and ivanka are coming up
now
i got here oh this is a wild card you
just don't know what's going to go on in
there
thank you joe thanks joe
first super hearts thank you somebody
else gave us super hearts too
thank you for the super hearts people uh
l i
j a i guess why elijah 249 superhearts
you have heard my father talk about
some of the things that he's been able
to accomplish over the past four years
and i am so proud of so many of them but
i will say
the thing that i am most proud of
is unlike politicians he's
never forgot why he ran for president
and who he is fighting for you
never forgot it is
a beautiful thing to see and he works so
so hard
every single day and let me just tell
you
washington has not changed donald trump
donald trump has changed washington
true it's true and there's more to come
so now we have to fight for him and we
have to fight for this country
that we love so much and get out and
vote tomorrow
thank you wisconsin we love you and god
bless
thank you sweetheart george would you
like to say something about peace in the
middle east
to this very small crowd better start
taking care of those apartments
if the things that the politicians were
talking about we're easy to work
ago but it took a leader like president
trump to come in
a little bit but we've seen things going
on that's the wrong one to put up there
and we will never stop fighting to get
all the things done that president trump
has promised so
thank you for your support thank you for
your love
chris christie wants to talk to you
yeah he does he's got some issues that
he wasn't hired
thank you thank you everybody
thanks everybody and i see some people
do i see corey lewandowski back there
yes do i see david is that david
president trump you got another rally
baby
david somebody give him the hand
he's acting like this is the last rally
we don't have to hear from them
the mic doesn't work anyways oh great
job
great job good luck on television
tomorrow i think you're going to have a
blowout tomorrow okay
but i want to thank look i have a great
family i have a family they're working
all the time
all of them and we appreciate it special
people
and we're really you know we didn't need
this we had a wonderful
super it was just going good then i said
you know maybe i'll give it a shot
you know why because of trade it started
because of trade i hate it
i watched it was so obvious the way we
were being ripped off on trade
and i said let's give it a whirl and i
said to my wife i'd like to do it what
do you think she said well you have to
really want it
because you know you will win don't you
i said do you think so really
she had more uh a little more security
in the fact that if i ran nurse she said
you will win if you but you have to make
sure you want it i said
i want to do it because we have so many
things we could do i never thought we
would have done what we've done though
we've done
a lot together together we've done so
much i mean you think about all
it probably started more i talked to ron
about it probably started with trade
though because
i hated our companies were leaving to
mexico canada china they were all
leaving our country we had these stupid
laws and horrible
tax deals where they had incentives to
move to mexico they got
incentivized to move to mexico somebody
had a concept
gee let's make mexico great again you
know i said no
i want to make our country great again
so that's the story it's a complicated
story but
it all evolved into this evening and
tomorrow we have our big day
and tomorrow i think that uh i think
it's going to be a really special day
and i hope you can all go out
you'll find the time and go out and vote
and we're going to make you very proud
you're going to make
you're going to be made really very
proud i just finished you off for
decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations fighting foreign wars and
defending foreign borders but now we're
finally protecting our nation rebuilding
our cities and we are bringing
our jobs and our factories and our
troops
finally finally find that we're bringing
them back home to the usa where they
belong
for 47 years joe biden viciously
attacked
black americans he called young black
men super predators all the time
every black american i am asking you to
go out tomorrow and vote it's very
important
this is your one and only chance to show
sleepy joe biden what you think of his
decision to attack you
to jail you and to betray you i'm
fighting for you
and we got criminal justice reform
completed
prison reform completed opportunity
zones completed with the great tim scott
of south carolina
and funding for historically black
colleges and universities we got that
done
and i say all the time and sometimes
people say that's a big statement then
they realize it's true
with the exception of abraham lincoln
there's never been
a president that has done so much for
the black
community and it's my honor it's my
honor
it is my honor and under my leadership
and by the way i don't know if you've
been watching what's going on in florida
we're doing really well
and you know what they're talking about
the black community
and the hispanic american community is
really
they're liking trump what's going on now
we're doing very
well florida florida is doing very well
so in conclusion over the next four
years
we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all
it's already begun we will hire more
police increase
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
with god's help we will defend the right
to life
religious liberty free speech
and the right to keep and bear arms your
second amendment
which is totally under siege but as long
as
ron johnson and your great congressmen
are there we will protect it right glenn
everybody
we will protect it wrong that's an easy
one for us
but it wouldn't be easy if he got it we
wouldn't have enough to say about it
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military
might and we will ensure peace through
strength we will end surprise medical
billing
require price transparency starts on
january 1st and it will be bigger than
health care
lower drug prices even more favored
nations the drug companies do not like
me too much i will tell you want the
lowest drug prices anywhere in the world
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and we will restore patriotic education
it's going to be
you leah you keep messing with me uh-huh
we will teach our children to love our
country what
history
for years you had a president who
apologized to america
we had a sister i mean we have had i
watched
obama go out and apologize all over the
world
he would apologize all over the world he
apologized
for america now you have a president who
is standing up for america and standing
up
for the great great people of wisconsin
tomorrow you have the power you have the
vote you have
the power really to save america we
can't go down that path
we will never be a socialist country
we will never be
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your co-workers grab
your boss by the tie
and say come on boss we got to get out
and vote get out and vote
from madison to milwaukee from
janesville to lacrosse
and from your team is doing well right
your team is doing well green bay green
bridge
do you like you like your quarterback i
do i like your quarterback
you know who i like we like brett favre
do you like bradford
do you know that brett endorsed me last
week huh
we love brett favre what a great guy i
got to know him he's a
he's a tough cookie he's a tough guy a
great great
guy green bay to right here in kenosha
we inherit the legacy of american
patriots who gave their blood sweat and
tears
to defend our country and to defend our
freedom
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes
who crossed the oceans settled the
continent
tamed the wilderness laid down the
railroads
raised up the great skyscrapers won two
world wars
defeated fascism and communism and made
america into the single greatest nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet to come
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are returning power to you the
american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep forward fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning winning winning you
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious nation
under god and together with the
incredible people of wisconsin
we have made america powerful again
we have made america wealthy again your
401ks are doing very well
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again we're
proud
again we're respected we're respected
again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you wisconsin thank
you wisconsin
go out and vote thank you it's a great
honor
ladies and gentlemen that was president
trump in kenosha wisconsin
uh i'm not gonna say it was he went
long because i don't know how long he
was supposed to go
but he does have another venue that he
needs to get to
um tonight he's dancing and we will be
bringing it to you uh
so that's it
he's supposed to be good now yeah i
don't know
he's supposed to be pulling in and
getting ready here in about 15 i think
it's going to be held off for at least
an hour
get yourself together get yourself
together come on back uh
yeah go down and click the alert button
or
right and then alert them when we come
back on subscribe
on do that if you haven't done subscribe
on facebook subscribe on youtube
um click the notification button and the
bell
so that you know when we go notification
live i'm i i might me myself i might
start this around
11 15 and we might filter in
one after the other because you know my
co-hosts also have families
if you have um if you would like to uh
donate or contribute to what we do use
patreon.com forward slash wd show
uh you can become a monthly contributor
that way you can also um
on periscope your super hearts are
donations uh they i like watching them
too on the screen they like pop and
like do all kind of fun stuff yeah it's
really cool
um but periscope you can do it that way
youtube if you want to do a donation
through youtube you can uh i'm not
monetizing any videos on youtube anymore
on the first time i had a youtube
account i had almost a thousand and they
took it down
no 100 000 subscribers and he took it
down
second time i had it it was between 50
and 65
000 and they took that down so
you know i don't even the reason why i
have youtube is because i know some of
y'all like to watch it
on youtube so with that said i'm gonna
let y'all roll out
get refreshed do whatever you have to do
um
i'm gonna start this back live in about
another
hour uh and then we're gonna let
president trump do what he does
in grand rapids and um
this will be his last this this will be
his last re-election rally ever
right so make sure
to watch yep make sure that you um
get out there and vote if you don't come
back make sure that you come get out
there and vote many of you said
you're going to vote and don't let the
media
fool you if you're standing in line to
vote and they're saying we're going to
call this state early and it looks like
it's going to be a winner here for joe
don't let them fool you stay in that
line and get your vote
in that's a lie stay in line and vote
no matter what they say you stay in that
line of vote
if you see somebody that is out there
that
is trying to cause issues or you see a
group out there you need to put it on
camera
upload it somehow get it to exactly
upload it to your local officials
exactly exactly and
if you tag us we'll be sure to share it
on social media too
uh but document it don't get in
anybody's face
don't cause no issues just document it
and upload it so people know what's
going on at your polling place
you don't have to show us who you voted
for you know you're on track
we are asking you to if you see
something nasty
crazy funny funky documented but if
you're a late voter and you've got to
wait till after work
don't listen to what the media is saying
just get out there and vote
hopefully you aren't that late we don't
want you to be that late
some people at work i know i know i
don't know
brian any last words real quick
you're muted bud you're moving music
that was so you guys couldn't hear me
talking but okay
no according to dance covino um there
was probably anywhere from 25 to 30 000
at the rally
according to ronald mcdaniels there are
tens of
thousands of people who have not yet
voted that are at these rallies that
were registered democrat
that are at the trump
right how they're going to vote but
they're registered democrat former
they haven't they didn't vote in 2016 or
maybe some of them did but there's tens
of thousands
that are going to vote now i'm just
going to be bad it's going to be real
well i hope they'll i hope they they
become millions
because like i said we really need to
double and triple
uh democrats on election day we don't
want it close
leah bryant we don't know we're not
asking you to do it close ladies and
gentlemen
because if you're doing it close you're
not doing that man uh
no you don't you can't stop pennsylvania
because i'm telling you
can't i know pennsylvania's in play but
you have to take pennsylvania
off the table because there's probably
going to be a cheat there i'm just going
to say it like it is
i'm in this i'm in the state i don't
like what's going on
i'm hearing the chatter in the state
they don't like what's going on it could
be a cheat
so you've got to take pennsylvania out
of this
and go from there we need if you look
right if you look at the different
possibilities
he absolutely can win without
pennsylvania
but we want to have pennsylvania well we
do
but we need all the other states to step
up isn't it funny how
we see are we here like
which um shut down dc
or whatever that d we hear what they're
gonna do
we see them planning what they're going
to do
and we just let them go ahead and do it
isn't it weird to you
something so seriously wrong yeah you
know
we'll talk about it we'll talk about it
later all right ladies and gentlemen do
what you have to do
we gotta go we'll see you in a few
washington around 11 15 11 30. that's
right
come on man
you